それ 仏教から見ればどうなるのかというと
真理 事実であるならば
判断は常に一貫している
もし事実であるならば
もう判断はもう一つしかないんですよ
だからそんな曖昧にならないはずじゃないかなと
良いと悪いとはっきり決められないのではないかなと
本当ははっきり決められるはずなんですね
どんな問題にも答えがあるはずなんです
ですから これではっきりした判断するために
我々はどんなものを勉強すればよろしいかということを勉強していきます
まず 生きる目的を決めなくてはいけない
これから言うものは 俗世間ででも
学校ででも会社でも教えてくれない世界
だから覚えた方がなんとか役に立つ可能性はあります
ただ単に生きるんじゃなくて
生きる目的は何？何のために生きるのかということ
これしっかりした方がいいんじゃないかなというのが仏教の考え方なんですね
何のために生きるのかと発見しておけば
生き方に対してほとんどの問題は解決する
私は何のために生きるのかとわかったら
あ このために生きているんだといえば
ちゃんと生き方が出てくるんですよ
しかし 仏教の真理の立場から生きる目的は発見できないんです
私はそっちを言ってますから
生きる目的なんかはないんだと
ゼロだと だから大変なの
生きる目的さえあればしっかり生きられるのに
問題は そんな目的なんかは本来はないんです
でも心配することはないんです
また別な答えがあるんです
すごい意欲を持って生命は生きることに挑戦する
しかし 我々は目的がないということを発見できてないんでしょ
その代わりに我々はものすごい意志があって
意欲があって 一生懸命生きているんですよ
それだけはわかりますね
目的も知らないくせに
もう頑張って生きているんです
生命は楽しみ 幸福 安らぎを求めて生きることに挑戦するんですよ
だから覚えてほしいのは
我々は安らぎ 幸福 楽しみ
幸せ 何か欲しいんです
そのために挑戦しているんです
それを理解しておけば
楽しむために生きているんだと
簡単でしょ 幸福になるために生きているんだと
幸福になるために頑張って挑戦しているんだと
だから幸福になるために
楽しくなるために生きているんだからといって
楽しくなることは人生の目的ということではないんですよ
それは別な話で だから一応私たちはその自分の程度で理解してほしい
自分はまあ楽しみを目指して
楽しみ 楽しくなるために
幸福になるために一生懸命頑張っているのではないかと
だから答えは簡単 だったら楽しくなりなさいよと
ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃあれやあれ
あれやこれやとかね 自分の幸福を壊すんじゃなくて
すごい単純に 素直に楽しく生きていればいいでしょ
それさえも理解していないんだから
何のために生きるのかと
あるいは自分が何のために生きているのかと
それわかってほしい すごいシンプルですよ
楽しいんだったらやる人間でしょうに
何でも これは幼稚園の子供からおじいさんまでみんな同じなんですよ
楽しいんだったらやるという生き方でしょ
楽しくないんだったらやめると
なんでそれを素直に認めないんですかね
それは素直に認めると
もう生き方はすごく変わるんですよ
もっと楽しい世界になるんです
それが終わってから次に幸福の原因というのを勉強するんです
1番目は まあ目的というかね
何のために生きているのかっていうことを理解する
それを理解するだけで
結構人生は変わります
次に幸福の原因を理解する
これも淡々と書きますので
もうあんまり難しいこと
で 幸福と不幸の原因があるんです
これは仏教で言えば貪瞋痴と不貪不瞋不痴ということなんですね
いわゆる欲 怒り 無知は不幸の原因で
で 欲がない状態 怒りがない状態
無知がない状態は幸福になるんですね
頭が悪くて幸せになったってことはありえないでしょ
頭が良い人は幸せになる
いつでも怒りっぱなしの人は
すぐ怒るんだから あなたは幸せですよと
ありえないでしょうに
すぐ怒る人と友達もなくなっちゃうし
もう最悪状態になるんだから
これは不幸の原因なんですよね
えらい欲張りだから幸せってことはないでしょう
みんなに嫌われますよ
だからそんなのはシンプルでわかりますよ
誰が嫌われちゃって 誰が好かれるのかと
欲がなくない人が好かれる
そう簡単には怒らない人
いつでもニコニコとしている人はまた好かれる
また頭が良い人はまた好かれるんだからね
だからそこで幸福不幸の原因というのはすごいシンプルなことでわかると思います
日々の生き方で不幸の原因に負けることは
悪いこととして判断できる
はい そこであの第1位
誰にもできなかったことを世の中で
この基礎概念を作ること
仏教はやっているんです
生きるために 善悪判断するために基礎概念を作ってください
これでこれ基礎概念になるんです
日々の生き方で 毎日毎日生きていることで
会社に行ったり帰ったり
学校に行ったり帰ったり
買い物に行ったり帰ったりする
もう毎日の生き方で この毎日普通に生きている上
普通に生きている時は
あの貪瞋痴が現れないようにと気をつけるんです
だから教科書は簡単です
貪瞋痴が現れないように生きてみなさい
ただそれだけ 欲と怒りと無知が現れないように自由に生きてください
何やってもいいんだよと
音楽家になろうか もう知識人になろうか
会社の社員になろうが
それは勝手に何でもいいんだよと
あなたの将来はただ単に何やってもいいんだけど
貪瞋痴だけ現れないようにしてくださいと
そうなるとかなり幸福にはなります
なぜならば 貪瞋痴は不幸の原因ですから
それで生きる目的といったら
何のために生きているかというと
楽しくなるために生きているんです
それは 日々の生き方はそのまま好転して良い生き方に回転しちゃうんです
論理的にも難しいことじゃないんです
で これ知らないんですよ
みんな 仏教の世界以外は
だからみんな失敗するんですよ
怒りも必要だと 欲も必要だと
戦うことも場合によっては必要やと
無知も必要だと 無知も必要だということは
もう何でもかんでも人間に知ることはできないんだから
神様の話も聞く必要があるんだよという話なんです
それと無知が必要だということなんです
だから世の中ではなかなか知らないんだから
とにかく欲や怒りをね
育てちゃいますから 不幸な世界になるんですよ
だからこれを覚えておいた方が人生は生きやすい
我々のは生きる時は教科書がありますと
基礎的な基準があるんだと
貪瞋痴が現れないように
貪瞋痴というのは欲と怒りと無知ですね
欲と怒りと無知が現れないように気をつけて生きてみる
何もやめる必要はないんです
遊ぶことをやめる必要もないし
もう仕事を辞める必要もないし
友達関係をやめる必要もないし
もう何もことなく普通に生きていればいいんです
ごく普通に しかし このごく普通に生きている時は
ちょこっとした善悪 良いか悪いか判断する基礎基準を持っています
もう信じられないほど人生が変わると思いますよ
例えば商売する人がいるとする
普通に商売すればいいんです
商売やっている途中でどんどん欲が入ってくると
これすごく危ないんです
見栄が入ってくるとすごく危ないんです
堀江さんと同じくなっちゃうんです
とにかく世界一になるんだぞと
何でもかんでもと思ったところで大失敗するんですね
だから彼はすごい才能がある
ものすごいもう明るい才能もある
能力もある立派な人でしたけど
やっぱりその中で貪瞋痴が絡んできて
もう負けちゃったんですね
それは欲怒りなく もう株の売買やら何でも何でもかんでもやっていたならば
淡々と会社が大きくなって大きくなってね
ものすごい安定して大きくなっていくだけで
だから理性よりは欲やら高慢やらね
見栄やら それで怒りもね
いろんな会社潰して自分の方が大きくするぞというね
そういう感情が出たら
もうそれで終わっちゃうんですね
全部 だからこれっていうのは冗談の話じゃないんですよ
もう負けてしまいます
欲 怒り 無知が入ると負ける
だから我々は学校で勉強する人は学校で勉強するわ
会社に行く人は会社でもそんなのはどうでもいいことで
会社自分で運営している人は自分で会社を運営すればよろしいし
政治家は自分の政治活動をやればよろしいし
もう人は自分やっていることをそのままやればいいんです
それで基本的にこの何と言いますか
テキストが必要なんです
どのように生きるべきかって
地層がない これが貪瞋痴が現れないようにという
すごいシンプルなことなんです
貪瞋痴が出てくると 自分の道が崩れていくんです
で 不幸になるんです 誰にもどうすることもできなくなるんです
幸福になる原因に基づいて生きることは良いことと判断できる
それで我々は幸福になるために生きるんだから
幸福の原因に基づくことは良いことだと
いわゆる欲をなくすこと
怒りをなくすこと 無知をなくすことは良いことで
自分に対しても 体に対しても
頭に対しても良いことで
で 逆は悪いことだと理解しておけば
これで良いか悪いか判断できる能力がつくんです
最終的に心から不幸の原因を完全に取り除くことは目的ゴールにする
で この 2番目 この 3番目の行で
こちら辺で書いたのは
このあの目的基準の 1番目
これは  3 2番目 それで
もし人が貪瞋痴で不幸になるならば
心からこれ完全に消しちゃえばどうですか？とか
もう生まれないよ だから金儲かるよりも良い会社に
もうもう仕事を昇格するよりも
一番大事なのは心の貪瞋痴をなくすことではないか
そうすると問題解決じゃないかなということで
生きる目的はそれ 何でしたっけ？心の貪瞋痴を消すこと
それがゴールなんです
それで基礎概念があって
ゴールがあって 2つあります
良いか悪いか決めるために
仏教の 3番目はあまり使わない
適当に判断するっていうことは
で それで判断は一貫するんですよね
良い悪いの判断をする時
仏教は 1生きる基準を作ること
生きる基準というのは
僕 普通に生きてるんだけど
貪瞋痴が現れないようにするっていうこと
それは生きる基準 何をやっても貪瞋痴だけは割り込まないようにするんだよっていうことは
生きる基準 これ 1番目
2番目 目的ゴールを定めることという 2つを使用します
仏教は 2番目 なんか目的がないと生きていられないんだからね
目的を作るです 目的っていうのは世界一になる目的ではなくて
それは欲だからね 心の貪瞋痴を完全に取り除くという
それが目的なんです その 2つしてくださいと
それで一貫した善悪判断はできます
生かしてますよ だって
日常生活の場合でも貪瞋痴をなくすように生きているんだから
ゴールも貪瞋痴をなくすことだから
いつでも善悪判断はいつでも一貫しているんです
曖昧がなくなっちゃうんです
3のその場で判断することは使用しないんです
仏教は この基準はすべての生命に適用する事実です
これでこれ逃げられません
仏教の真理からは 仏教で言うことは
すべての生命に適用するんです
わざわざ仏教は生命に強引に
これは聖書だから学びなさいということを言っているわけじゃないんです
これは事実だよと 知ったもんじゃないんだと
仏教からブッダからは
だからどんな生命でも貪瞋痴で不幸になる
不貪不瞋不痴で幸福になる
その生命が犬であろうが
猫であろうが ミミズであろうが
知ったものじゃないんです
神様であろうが知ったものじゃない
どんな生命にもこれが普遍的に適用できるんだから
ということで 仏教は一貫した判断をつくんです
曖昧はない世界なんです
で テーマ変えます